our brain is made up of billions of
neurons and they are connected to each
other by junctions known as synapses in
order to talk to each other our brain
uses electrical signals that travels
down to the axon and reaches the
synapses and thereby they form action
potentials and these action potentials
can lead to vesicle release or
neurotransmitter release in the synaptic
cleft here action potential which is
flowing down the North terminals is
causing a vesicle release in the
synaptic cleft but how this action
potential can cause vesicle release is a
question so synaptic vesicles filled up
with neurotransmitter are just like a
ship trying to dock to the port and when
it when the ship comes closer to the
port if the true its anchor and their
way it can dock similarly our
neurotransmitter vesicles have anchor
like things known as snare proteins and
these snares our vesicle bound snares
and other side the target membrane or
the synaptic the synaptic active zone
membrane has target snares of T snares
and this T snare and v snare interaction
can allow the vesicle fusion of the
neurotransmitter vesicles if we zoom
into the details of this
neurotransmitter vesicle fusion we would
see their proteins like synaptotagmin
sin actor breathing which is helping to
sense the action potential and allowing
the snare interaction the vesicle snare
and the target membrane snare
interaction there are other proteins
like systems - in proteins monk 18 and
syntax in which is stabilizing the scene
and the snare interactions now when
action potential flows down to the the
bags on there is calcium increase and
the calcium increase is sensed by a
protein like synaptotagmin which has
I'm sensing domains like see two domains
and thereby it can allow conformational
change and converting lose near complex
to a tight snare complex and thereby
ultimately bringing the two membrane of
the vesicle and the target membrane so
closer that they can fuse to each other
and thereby releasing the
neurotransmitters and once the
neurotransmitter is released the t snare
and v snare interaction is resolved by
proteins like NSF they have Proteus
activity which can cleave of the
interaction and thereby recycling a new
round of t snare into the system and if
I talk about the vesicle release there
are multiple type of synaptic vesicles
some are readily releasable like which
are talk to the membrane and just
waiting for a signal tripolis there are
recycling pools and their result phul
which are not released frequently so
about this kind of vesicle pools I would
be talking into my next video hope this
video helped you and thanks for watching
please subscribe like and share thank
you